eine partei die in großen teilen oder
ganz breite erklärt gekommen unseren
vorsitzenden keine wahl gewinnen muss
sich einen neuen vorsitzenden suchen
also ich finde solche stelle mir gerade
vor meiner partei fdp wäre das so dass
die leute wollen sagen wenn mit linda
können wir die wahl nicht gewinnen dann
muss man sagen dann ist ja nicht die
richtige vorsitzende und das finde ich
ja spektakulär dass die partei in den
wissen dass sie einen kandidaten wählt
als parteivorsitzender auch
kanzlerkandidat werden will
in dem wissen dass markus söder gesagt
hat ich bleibe in bayern mein platz ist
in bayern heute erklärt wegen
irgendwelcher meinungsumfragen wir
müssen von unserem vorsitzen abrücken
wie soll denn armin laschet die nächste
landtagswahl in nordrhein westfalen
gewinnen diese in einem jahr also wenn
wir sagen wir können mit ihnen keine
wahl gewinnen die westfalen auch nicht
gewinnen dann ist sie jetzt gleich
ministerpräsident zwischenzeit ist so
absurd was wir uns gerade vorgeführt
wird
ich bin also mich bringt das ich schlafe
aber ich bin relativ fassungslos wie
eine große demokratische partei sich so
aufführt